[Applause]
[Music]
all right here we go you better be loud
happy Wednesday everyone so was it just
a speech or will they really impeach but
first what's the latest on the biton
crime family
yeah pretty good specifically Commander
the new first family dog whose taste for
human flesh Rivals the cast of
outnumbered
you didn't know that did you anyway the
first dog they got for publicity
purposes major had a hit the road for
biting he was part German Shepherd and
part Brian stelter
laughs
of course Joe accused one secret service
agent of lying about being bitten at
least we know the teeth weren't Joe's he
keeps them in a jar on top of the
nightstand
nonetheless major was replaced by
commander who is now biting people
Commander bit seven people over a
four-month period including two Secret
Service agents and a worker at Biden's
Delaware home but hey you'd be a cranky
dog too if they kept blaming you for the
messes that Joe leaves on the carpet
oh you're terrible okay I'll take it
but that's only the eighth or ninth
worst thing that happened to the Biden
White House this week and now house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy is using the I
word that's impeachment
meanwhile Joe's degenerate crackhead son
is embroiled in one Fiasco after another
and Joe is in the middle of most of them
so like my immense Talent it's becoming
too much to hide anymore there's barisma
the Energy company that hired Hunter for
his expertise using butane to heat up
his crack pipes
and there's the Shady Fine Art scam some
broad buys a picture a special ed art by
a and then gets a plum assignment
at a prestigious Commission
if that's not a quid pro quo I'm
unattractive
and we know that's not true
there's Joe's seventh granddaughter who
he still won't acknowledge I could go on
but I don't want to bore you like Jesse
Waters
because that's his job
why'd the CIA lie to the voters before
the last election about the laptop why
did the FBI censor the laptop why were
RSS IRS investigators prevented from
pursuing leads against Joe Biden why'd
the Biden family constantly get tipped
off why were search warrants blocked why
do you set up
two dozen shell companies if you have a
legitimate business what is the Biden
family business
that's the most impressive thing he's
ever done
and he once read a book
but that's a clear case for impeachment
and what does Joe have to say about all
this
is
finally we know how to get him to shut
up either the battery crapped his pants
and was running to the bathroom
so they lie cheat steal launder they
exploit the office oh wait sorry I'm
getting word that the president cured
cancer
I said I'd cure cancer they looked at me
like why cancer because no one thinks we
can
that's why and we can
I mean and the cancers we know it
um
forget everything I said
he cured cancer
story's over but there's bigger news
after his plea deal fell apart Hunter
pled not guilty today to federal tax and
gun charges it happened after the judge
wouldn't promise immunity from future
prosecutions including foreign lobbying
but leave it to cringe to dodge
questions about Hunter I wonder if she's
been asked this question multiple times
and if nothing has changed
I was asked this question multiple times
on Monday nothing has changed as I
stated on Monday when I was asked this
question multiple times nothing has
changed nothing has changed on this
nothing has changed on this uh and so
you could ask me a million different
ways on this question nothing has
changed other things that haven't been
changed her incompetence
if I was this bad at my job I'd be fired
or at least become judge jeanine's
driver
meanwhile the judge also threatened his
legal team with sanctions after they
allegedly tried to get testimony from
IRS whistleblowers removed by
impersonating lawyers for the House GOP
over the phone I mean who are these
lawyers The Jerky Boys
well I know that's a call back so
impeachment or not the stench of
corruption Rivals the views bathroom on
Taco Tuesday
speaking of I wonder what the view had
to say
what bribery scheme yes how much
punishment does Biden need because he
won and they lost well that's the
problem they keep seeing these
indictments coming down from Trump and
they're like what are we going to do
let's turn it around and make it about
him about Biden instead take it lies off
of trump even though he's a criminal and
put your eyes on this guy yeah
rather put at least they got their looks
what about impeachment Bill Clinton was
impeached for putting his junk where it
wasn't supposed to go or was it was it
his cigar I can't remember either the
way he lied about it under oath but in
retrospect that seems as minor as the
girls Joe likes to sniff
hell Bill didn't even leave any cocaine
laying around the White House it was a
different sort of white stuff but here's
the thing
thank you but here's the thing Donald
Trump was impeached for just talking
about the barisma Scandal it only seems
fair to impeach Joe for participating in
the barisma Scandal but I hate
impeachments because it's all political
team sport imagine in the Super Bowl One
coach could stop the game by suing the
other coach for trying to win and that's
what they did to Trump and the media
loves it as long as it's a republican on
the spit so I say impeach away they
wasted our time let's waste theirs and
it's deserved Joe instructed his Dirtbag
son to make it rain in exchange for
influence if that's not another quid pro
quo I'm Perry Mason in a moo moo
but why stop there let's impeach
everybody Jill Biden insists on being
called doctor has she ever set a broken
bone nope her husband's a corpse so at
best she's a coroner
and what does she do if somebody in a
movie theater has a heart attack and she
hears is there a doctor in the house
does she stand up and say yes I am a
doctor of Education would you like to
hear my thoughts on mentoring and
literacy I say impeach her and what
about Kamala she hasn't broken any laws
that I know of because she hasn't done
period
her
her idea of A Hard Day's Work is a few
hours of cackling and then a nap
what about my orcas he's letting more
drug smugglers than my bachelor party
mayor Pete hey none of the
transportation problems are his fault
after all he was on vacation
but hell we could fill the next three
months with impeachments because if
you're going to get rid of Commander
because he bites get rid of this whole
administration because they bite to
[Applause]
on the street and under park benches too
actor writer comedian Jamie listow
he's the best Canadian import since
billowing clouds of wildfire smoke
professor and author of the book The sad
truth about happiness Gad sad
she's luckier than Nancy Pelosi's
eyebrows Fox News contributor captive
and finally he rules between the ropes
and won't tolerate dopes by Massive
sidekick in the nwa's World Heavyweight
Champion Tyrese
Jamie as everybody knows you live in
Alaska do you follow what goes on in
America yep
um as soon as I get here yeah
um oh my God I'm sorry this just coming
in uh it turns out the president
misspoke he did not cure cancer he got
rid of a canker sore he's very sorry
he's very sorry I've thought in the mall
I thought it was very funny the thing he
did about the the Dr Jill yeah Biden
because that's really true like in a
movie theater people should be more
specific they shouldn't go is there a
doctor in the house they should be like
is there a doctor that could help in the
house exactly because what if you go is
there a doctor in the house this guy's
like I'll help you and he said I'm a
foot doctor and then I'll massage your
feet while you die yeah
um
this uh I'm enjoying the dog store I
like that they call it the first dog
right isn't that kind of cool like the
White House dogs because did you know
they can't call it um the first
because that was taken uh when Bill
Clinton was President
I think it's cool that Hunter has a dog
sniffing dog you know you know it's a
drug sniffing dog really but not like
one that works for the cops just one
that will do cocaine with him
one last thing the cleaning thing is
amazing to me that Hunter sold was it
like 1.3 million dollars do we think
this is like a really expensive version
of telling your kids they're good at
drawing yes
like but some of them are pretty cool
like one of them well some of them are
like interactive like interactive like I
saw one guy snort the snow off of a
Mountaintop yes
all right God congrats on the book uh
can we show the cover there look at the
cover it looks like a man talking to a
12 year old boy saying I'm gonna be your
new daddy
that never works out I know you're
you're my your mother and I deeply love
each other you can still see your
original dad
but you answer to me now the sad truth
about happiness so good here isn't that
weird that your name influences the
things that you do your name is sad but
you end up writing a book about
happiness that's very strange you know
that in Arabic sad means happiness and
Felicity oh really oh yeah so it's I was
meant to write this book wow I know my
name is Gutfeld and I have so many
stomach issues
I'm not kidding my whole life is about
about intestinal distress
it's amazing I can make it through a
show what do you make it's going do you
have um do you have President you're in
Canada right you have a president a
prime minister prime minister can we
impeach him from America
I'd like to impeach him from the
universe yeah I know but but speaking of
corruption when we first moved from
Lebanon to Canada my dad was constantly
receiving a lot of uh parking tickets
and so he went around trying to look for
the cop that he couldn't grease so that
he would never receive a parking ticket
and when people explain to him that
that's not how it's done in Canada his
answer was what kind of barbaric country
is Canada and so what happens is that
corruption becomes an endemic part of
the cultural values of a society
so it amazes me that now in the United
States I actually went through the
corruption perceptions index which ranks
every country U.S is now number 24 out
of 180. if he gets a second term they're
going to head towards Somalia which is
in number 180 yeah so exactly and uh um
and who's number one you know it's one
of the Scandinavian countries they don't
count though why is that well I mean
it's Scandinavia I mean I don't even
know what that is Scandinavia is that
one country or like five I mean if you
have to go as a group together to a
party that's kind of lame
anyway I'll shut up about Scandinavia
they don't air the show here Kat so what
do I care
um do are you pro-impeachment or
anti-impeachment
well look I think that it was pretty
clear what was going on it's been pretty
clear what's been going on this entire
time I think that this deal this plea
deal when they said has there ever been
anything like this before and everyone
was like no
I I don't know how it's not clear that
there's one main difference here what's
going on and that he's the president's
son but also I'm sure that Hunter was
very shocked that this didn't work out
for him right everything always does
does once you get your dead brother's
widow to agree to date you yeah and you
convince your dad to go to the press and
say not only is it okay but he's
actually happy for you you must think
you could convince anyone of anything
yeah and then going back to that in what
Universe are you calling your dad to be
like hey Dad can you please tell
everyone how it is actually good that
I'm having an affair with my dead
brother's widow and not say Hey Dad I
have a question about work yeah obvi
like that would that be too personal
obviously he was talking to him about it
and the White House has also changed
being like oh he wasn't in business with
him before they were saying he wasn't
talking to him about it so I think that
obvious I mean everybody knows everybody
knows they're doing crimes yeah they're
a crime syndicate Tyrus uh I want to ask
you because you are a you have many pets
what's going on with the dog nothing's
wrong with the dog and I'm glad you
brought this up because it's always
focused and I was actually pissed dogs
are reflections of their owners just
like kids are so are we surprised at all
yeah that his dogs are attacking
everyone
his his son is robbing everyone
and his dog's biting everyone because
he's a bad dog owner and a bad parent
the bad president he's just all around
bad but it's not the dog's fault they
don't socialize the dogs so that's why
the dogs do that bad behavior because of
because well I mean he probably forgets
he even has the damn dog so yeah
the little hairy guy that he met yeah
like that's the thing I feel bad for the
dogs yeah and the Secret Service ages
because these are really nice Secret
Service ages because back in the day you
would have heard her bang yeah
that's true yeah hey if it was me I mean
dog bites me once shame on you twice for
a coat
that's funny iris is so right that dogs
are a reflection of their owners I
remember when my wife left my dog
followed her
because he knew she'd keep feeding him
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else